mr. Michael Knowles the host of the
Michael Noel's show at The Daily wire a
very funny guy very smart guy
accomplished writer I could say I could
say writer kind of like that when I say
he was the author the author of the
number one best-selling book reasons to
vote for Democrats if if you don't know
why I say writer is very thorough you
should go in and look that book up
welcome to the program Michael Knowles
how are you Glenn thank you for having
me and thank you for your very generous
definition of the word writing so
Michael first of all have you been I
haven't talked to you in a while
it's good to hear for I've been doing is
good to hear for England I've been doing
well and I have been on my yeah Perkis
foundation lecture tour which is the men
are out women and other uncomfortable
truths lecture tour and I have never
seen a basic biological reality me such
protests I actually found myself I was
an assignment in a gender studies class
a gender studies class called
sex and love two of my favorite subjects
by the way actually assign the students
a protest against my speech not to come
see my speech but to protest the speech
so it's a pretty wild few weeks you know
it's really weird when I was in school
you would get extra credit by watching
something or going someplace listening
it and then having a conversation or
writing a paper on it we just just cut
right to the chase don't even listen
just protest this must have been a
hundred years ago that I mean I think
now the universities completely flipped
this on its head because what there was
a protester at this speech who on camera
you can see it on YouTube said the
reason for protesting is because this
speech you're literally violence and so
I mean I was my reaction to you I said
you know back in the way way back days
when I was in college just a few years
ago you would get extra credit if you
went listen to a lecture now you're
getting credit for protesting a lecture
the way that they've done it is because
they can't refute any
sort of conservative argument the only
way that they can fight back against our
argument is to censor us to shut us down
to protest us and the best way that they
can do that is to equate our speech with
violence because it then justifies their
own violence in return is absolutely
crazy
so you were where were you I I saw a
video I think it came Monday and you
were giving your your talk and outside
was this class let's roll some of the
video
everyone
[Music]
pull up to now happy to protect
transgender people on campus
he's transgender not
the high rates of
thank you
woman of color diet at an alarming rate
dude
okay thanks Tom so this was not exactly
I mean it was seemingly kind of well
attend it must have been maybe I don't
know 50 or 75 people there but they
weren't really it wasn't an exciting
Valley and some of the points they're
making like the high rate of transgender
being killed you know we looked it up
and in a three-year period there were
only three people that were transgender
that were murdered because they were
transgendered and that night all three
of them are involved the surprise that
apparently hit some people when they
believe they're about to hook up with a
woman and it maybe is not a woman robbed
that was the cause of three what you say
hook up it was their painting here those
things work yes the sex worker so you
know you don't run into the best class
of John's you know all the time using
the boulevard right right right you know
of course they totally manipulate the
statistics and it's all for this
emotional manipulation with funny is the
tour you know it takes its title from
the speech that I gave men are not women
where I first was very protested and
actually physically assaulted too and
but there are these other uncomfortable
truths at the two that I've been giving
the video you saw and the clip you
played was at Kennesaw State in Georgia
now I was at University of Florida last
night and the two other uncomfortable
truths were that the mainstream media
are fake news that you're being fed a
bill of goods from leftist propaganda
much like we heard in that clip and then
the next one I thought was more
important which is that leftism is not
compassionate and what they're saying is
that if we state very basic biological
realities that that's actually cool it's
leading to murder and it's leading to
suicide and none of the statistics back
that up at all but what they want to do
is is portray reality is cruel and
portray fantasy as compassionate and and
of course that simply isn't true
so Michael what is the what's the
reaction on campuses because I'm I'm
starting to see videos where there are
thousands of people that are turning out
positively for for conservative and I
use ham you see conserve just science
facts yeah there are many many multiples
more people who were turning out to
these lectures to engage in a productive
way you know I was at the University of
Florida last night one hundreds of
people there and it wasn't all
conservative students many were
moderates and a few of them were
left-wing and the less where's got up
there ask questions in a mostly
respectful way and it was really
productive and it's sort of what the
university is supposed to do is to
foster dialogue everybody can leave
hopefully having learned something I
think we've reached a tipping point with
the these sensors with these people who
are going to try to shut us down you
know they they tell you that anybody to
the right of Hillary Clinton is a
fascist and a bigot and a Nazi and a
murderer and I just think nobody really
believes and they may be simply gone too
far and at this point if you are going
to protest a basic fact you know men are
not women you might as well protest the
idea that two plus two equals four I
think the vast vast majority of people
know that the censors have lost
comparative and they're not going to
take it anywhere they're going to turn
out and they're not going to be robbed
of their University experience well
here's what's here's what's weird I I
agree with you I think people who are
independent I think a lot of Democrats
and conservatives they know all this I
really think most people are like come
on man I don't want to hate people I
don't hate people you want to do this
with your life in your own body that's
fine I don't necessarily agree with it
but I'm not you so go ahead and do
whatever it is that you want to do but
don't do it to kids you know and I think
that's where most people are the problem
is as we are starting to say this is
crazy
and I think on all fronts this is crazy
we have to have a conversation about
this the they have institution
not just in the schools but they've
institutionalized it in our government
when you have a seven-year-old in a
Texas court being told that his mother
can basically sterilize him and turn him
into a woman when you know forget it
even if that seven-year-old says yeah I
am I am I'm Carol Channing you don't do
that to a seven-year-old but here in
Texas that is happening
I mean if it's happening in Texas good
heavens what's happening in California
in New York I think people are seeing
this I mean I was shocked myself when I
saw the Texas decision and very little
shocks me these days I am in the news
24/7 and I couldn't believe it because
the the problem one's so much deeper
than we thought you know when you see
the people with the crazy hair and
you're yelling and screaming they're all
upset because of their leftist politics
it's easy to write that off and say okay
these are just fringe lunatic people and
the vast majority are normal but when
you have this institutionalized not just
in the judiciary but in the judiciary in
conservative places you realize how deep
the rot runs I think this is why these
conservative campus lecture series and
is actually independent campus lecture
series and the protests they meet are so
important too because it shows you how
deep the rot run even at elite
universities you know there was a study
out of ISI it shown that graduating
seniors at elite universities less about
their history and their government their
politics than incoming freshmen yeah
this is a really really deep problem and
it's going to take a lot more than one
or two elections one or two decisions to
turn it around